hi I'm Thomas I am at versel for those
of you who don't know what Versailles uh
basically it's like the Squarespace but
for people who do a little more
JavaScript to deploy your website so
um
yeah that's where I'm at I got into Data
um actually as a teacher I realized you
know I was scoring tests and giving
students feedback but one of the things
I realized was like I like didn't
actually understand
you know if you went from like a 40 one
test and to a 70 on your next test
you know that's a lot of growth but it
still wasn't a great grade right but it
was measuring the growth and I was like
oh man I can really I can call I should
quantify this so that was kind of my
first experience of really understanding
data
so ever sell I work on a lot of metrics
uh primarily product metrics so that's
what I'll be talking about today is
building out product metrics so
uh
the data experience at versel before we
started was like the worst side of
self-serve you can possibly do it was
like you had to self-serve to get data
it's like where you don't want people to
be they were jumping into the database
on every table uh and it just was chaos
uh once we started the team we were
putting out fire spray regularly in the
beginning
but our philosophy was we don't we don't
solve data problems we build Data
Systems so we've really really leaned
into that and this is one of the
products uh that we have built
So within the first year we were able to
kind of set up some of our systems
people to rely on you know putting
things behind git building out standard
dashboards and moving past the first
year is uh been really exciting we uh
have you know added streaming
architecture to allow teams to more
easily get data into the warehouse
so some of the problems that we dealt
with and if any of you all have
experienced any of these like you know
feel free to raise your hand or shake
your head bespoke data pipelines from
data from engineering teams
Uh custom metrics that don't necessarily
measure what people think they're
measuring
uh any anybody experience that one yeah
I I think one
one day someone's like our weekly metric
dropped I'm like
that's only six days how is that
possibly a weekly metric uh so another
one is time frames like what is a
monthly metric is it 31 days is it just
a month is it four weeks like what like
what are we even talking about
uh I mean missing random documentation
like you tracking someone down to
understand what's going on uh is was
really hard zero SQL standards I mean
people are writing ctes some people
writing nested queries it was really
hard for people to share queries with
each other
um
and then there was literally no concept
of a dashboarding experience it was all
over the place
so those are things that we really
struggled with so some of the some of
the victories we had were standardizing
inversion controlling our Pipelines
uh you know we were like oh we don't
have metrics so let's start at the
company level because everyone works at
the company and let's build metrics and
let's Cascade them down because at least
the company metrics will be applicable
to everyone
uh then we standardize on what is a
monthly and what is a weekly time frame
so no more six day weeks no more 31 day
months uh it was hard to compare
February to October which people were
doing and then their question was like
why do we say so much more growth in
October than from February and you were
like there's more days in October and
they were like oh yeah so we
you know
it's a process
we centralized all of our documentation
so there is no more like oh it's a
notion dock it's a GitHub repo oh it's
in this folder let me email it to you or
actually it's on my laptop let me just
slack it to you real quick it's all in
one place
the data team has to stamp your PR for
SQL if you want to get your metric
approved right we don't want to have any
more six day weeks
and then we we came up with this concept
that was I think pretty simple and
um
and I think something that a lot of
dashboarding companies are doing is like
they have these templates one of the
philosophies that we use at versel is uh
land learn and leave with our dashboards
you shouldn't have to go to a dashboard
learn how to use the dashboard and then
consume the content before you can leave
like you should already know before you
get there
like what the the topics or the layout
or the design should look like so we
like to use land learn and leave as our
approach
um
so
the other challenge was
um who who is our audience as a data
team now depending where you're at is
going to determine the audience of the
uh who you serve when we went to versel
we we realized there were three types of
people uh there were people using data
there were people wanting to use data
and they were people who will never use
data again because the service was so
terrible right they had like they were
done with it
uh so we some stakeholder our meetings
uh we asked people what what about data
is valuable to you
and what do you want out of data that
will help you do your job so you can go
home at 5 30. uh they said metrics it
was just an overwhelming metrics we
don't know where we're going we don't
know if our decisions have impacts those
metrics so to do that we decided we had
to find all of the data sources that
were valuable this isn't all of them but
the idea is there was more than one
right it wasn't like we were just going
to Salesforce we had to find all the
data sources that had meaningful impact
on our stakeholders
and we said then we said we will take
all data sources we're going to funnel
them into a single table right we're
going to build a place where we can
aggregate all of this information that
we can then explode out into many
metrics hence
the the title of the talk dozens of
metrics from one heterogeneous table
so as you can see we have different data
sources and then we come to the right
side of the chart these are like the
core attributes
um about the data so at versel we have a
concept of a user we have a concept of a
team and teams can have users and we
have projects which are like web pages
websites you know so a user can have a
project a user can own a project team
can own a project obviously a user can
deploy a team project so somewhere like
GitHub I have like users orgs repos we
have projects right
uh action product metrics groups I'll go
into more detail uh into this in a
little bit but uh I just want to pause
to see if this makes sense
cool yeah
so we chose date because a lot of our
ETL pipelines go at the date if you're
I'm just gonna I don't I don't trade
stock I'm not that smart let's just say
you were a stock Trader and you could do
things at the minute level maybe yours
would be minute right but it's all based
on the needs of your data maybe you
don't have a concept of
user team project or or maybe you have
an additional concept but maybe you have
a user team maybe you have a business
which a business could have many teams
and teams could have users right so this
is meant to fit the structure of your
company right yeah
per day average yeah I'm gonna get that
in a couple slides but it's a great
question
super simple and something that people
people love because it's it's extremely
concrete
so
um I'm just going to kind of walk
through we call this the metrics
enrollment table
um it's a I don't know it's an on the
nose name uh but it makes sense because
we're data people and I don't know
namings things are hard uh basically
it's a metric and this is how you enroll
in it right so hence the metrics
enrollment table uh it's the funnel for
all of our metrics
uh it's like a version controlled schema
so you're No One's Gonna push
information to it that can't exist there
which is uh we don't want our metrics to
break
the uh
structure it it forces a like usable
data pretty far Upstream on the
engineering side because the engineering
teams know what they need and their data
if they want to get it into the metrics
layer
or a metrics enrollment table
you don't need the data team anymore to
add new metrics we've like you can't
push things that can't be pushed here
but you can push things that can be
pushed here go for it
and then you know and the cool part my
favorite part about this talk is that
we're going to get into like a formula
for like how to like Define a metric so
not only do we use the table as kind of
like a metrics log we also use the table
as our formula for computing the dozens
of metrics in one heterogeneous table
my undergrad in sociology and like one
of my teachers said when you write a
paper yeah like tell them what you're
going to say say it and like tell them
what you said so I'm going to keep
coming back to the title as like dozens
of metrics and eventually it's gonna be
like past the mic
so
time frames we have three time frames uh
for sale uh daily is midnight to 11 59.
not a super used time frame we we use
this for basically one use case if you
launched a new product or have a new
marketing campaign you use this time
frame in the first week only
because that's all the data you can have
to compare time over time
so
your first week you can use daily once
you get past the first week you're we're
putting you on the weekly time frame
right so that way you can start
comparing weekly now
you'll notice on here that the weekly is
a seven day rolling average so you're
not you don't have to wait until Monday
to get your next weekly metric it's just
a constant seven day moving window
oh and we use the seven most complete
days hope that makes sense yeah
every day you have a new weekly metric
yep and it's the past seven days so this
is great yes
yeah I'll get into I'll get into that uh
a little bit the table design but yeah
that's a great question
uh and then we you'll you'll notice so
this is so this metric is really great
for like a new product or a new
marketing campaign like the first month
right we don't want people relying on
weekly metric weekly based metrics if
your product is like a year old right
it's too mature to be relying on time
frames that are too small it's it's
influenced too much by new events
the monthly one is our core time frame
and that is like the weekly one a 28-day
rolling time frame
uh not 31 not 30 uh 28 days does anyone
know why you'd want to go with a 28 days
I can tell you why we did uh
it gives you a very clean month over
month
yeah every day is represented
four times right so if you do a 30-day
rolling window the weekend could be
represented five times where the weak
days only represent four times and if
you're like versel where you have less
activity in the weekend your metric is
going to tank like every seven days and
the day team's gonna get asked why did
our metric drop three percent and you're
going to say because the weekend's in
there five times and they're going to
say why is the weekend in there five
times right so we do 28 days I know it's
called monthly but it's 28 days
but how do you account for the extra day
or two in the leap year
it's just always a rolling window right
so you just it's just oh it's
so you don't you know always reset back
to January 1. yep you can do it
different ways you can compare that data
the previous year you compare that day
to
but it's always a 28 day rolling window
and then for our finance teams we're
like we can't do that we just they just
look at the first day of the month right
so they came up the last 28 days but on
the first day of the month for like
their numbers
oh sorry
well so what so one of the metrics I'm
pushing for which we haven't kind of
solidified yet are like quarterly
you know last 90 days and then like
yearly right uh but we're working on
different versions of this it's a
process
they do and and
um I'll get that in a second with this
table it's a great question so
um you know like I said before we agree
all of our data sources into this one
table this is a fake data I made up this
is mostly the structure we use
um and I'm gonna walk you all through
the structure a little bit and as you
can see each record is in here with a
timestamp so you know for the back of
this question you're like to date month
you could calculate to date month off of
this table as well for your bespoke
metrics but what's nice is they can
still follow the similar pattern which
we'll get into later so
you know these are all of our ID columns
right as I said before users teams
projects blah blah actions is a is we're
going to come to finally really useful
is what a user is like engaging with the
product that like this is the thing
they're like doing uh the product is
like it sounds the the product area of
the user is engaging with so we have
these two core products we have where
you can deploy on your cell where you're
deploying there wow we're deploying your
your data
and then you have preview comments where
your previews you could like go and be
like hey we should change this color you
know we should do this thing right so
this is the different product areas then
we have the metric Group which is like
active user right and we're gonna you
can see how you can append on that daily
weekly monthly active user so we're
starting to see how we can make one row
into many metrics you know over time
The Source column is is really great for
me uh because I get asked the question
well why did our data change right
I forcel I pin the source column to a
file in GitHub say this file generated
this line of metric so that way if the
thing drops or increases five percent
I'm like who merged a PR to change this
code right I can track addresses all the
way back to like a get uh user who who
might have merged code
um a column we don't use very frequently
is the number of events because it's an
aggregated time to a time frame you
could use the number of events
one of my iterations for next year or
maybe
you know further down the line would be
using this identifier super users right
users who are doing something like many
many many many times in a day so you
could kind of develop this concept with
like a super user metric and then
finally use heavier timestamp
let's jump into the formula so I think
this is my favorite slide if this
doesn't resonate with you all I'm sorry
I was very excited about this slide I
had like 20 different colors on here for
how excited I was my wife was like
Thomas you can't have 20 colors on a
slide like you're going to lose
everybody and I was like but it's great
um so as you can see this is the the
formula for developing your metric right
you don't need every single one of these
inputs for every single metric but the
idea is you can use a combination of
these to develop your metric so I will
show you that later remember this we'll
also come back to it
um nice entity IDs to represent you know
the many entity IDs you could have
so this is one line from that data set
and this is how many metrics we're going
to generate and I will walk you through
those metrics so
this is my this is my line
so this is a top level company metric a
monthly active user
all I care about is their user ID the
time frame and and the fact that they
were in a metric group called activeuser
right we could have called this weekly
active user or daily active user they
would
the next one is monthly active team
member by checking to see if there was a
team ID and a user ID and they were in
an active user I'm now able to develop a
monthly active team member metric
I can do the same with teams checking
for a team ID
are we is this resonating okay cool I'm
going to skip these two for now and go
to the bottom oh we care about projects
so if a project idea is there
and you know under the active you know
under the metric group of active you get
the monthly active projects monthly
active team project the project ID and
the team ID so it's kind of hopefully
making sense
now
what's really nice about this is you can
start thinking about
how can I build a metric not not to
steal Evie's talk about the metric tree
he's his metric tree was great mine's
more of like a product metrics tree you
can start building this like metric tree
now right so you can add in the action
to this and you can start getting
something like a monthly active
developer which is now a subset of
monthly active user
so you can start breaking these things
apart and seeing how the sub metrics
feed the parent metric
so
you could you know if we have time I
have a couple slides post the question
if I haven't run out of time to to talk
about how like you could break that down
by country you could break that down by
age as a customer you can break that
down by billing plan so you can really
get super granular with these metrics
that kind of all roll up
I'm going to show you um the next slide
you'll notice that the first three rows
in the bottom two rows are the exact
same metric the only thing that really
changed was the action the user did they
had a preview comment so they're not
going to be a monthly active developer
they're a monthly active commenter
so you know so these two metrics feed to
the monthly active user and one of the
nice kind of data one of the nice things
data analysts can do with that is you're
like well we've seen a huge spike in our
monthly active contributors and we've
also seen a spike in our monthly active
users oh it came from these people using
this feature right so now the product
people can say oh yeah we've our new
product is kind of monthly active users
or you can say we've seen a huge spike
in monthly active you know commenters
but it didn't change the monthly active
users it's because
we're doing our distinct count of users
for monthly active users
people who are commenting are also
deploying so it's like the same people
are using both features so it allows the
analysts to get an understanding of like
how much breadth and width there are to
feature adoption and then you know how
much each one of these is influencing
the overall metric
so
then this isn't exactly true because you
could do weekly or daily it's also okay
for one line to map to one metric like
adult you don't have to get 30 metrics
or whatever per line of code so you can
just do one line to per metric
so
I'm going to go back over the formula
real quick like I said this is the
exciting thing for me I apologize if
it's not that exciting I think this is
like really great uh you know your time
frame determines your daily weekly
monthly
your entity IDs or a combination of your
entity IDs can determine you know as a
user as a team as a project is a team
project is it a team member that
determines that level of metric
and then you can use the actions to kind
of build out this
hierarchy this like tree of metrics you
can group some actions together maybe it
makes sense to group two or three
actions together into an actions you
know group then you can dissect those
even more
oh you know along with product right
product managers might not care about
the company level metrics so in the
company dashboard they can just filter
for their products and they get all
their uh you know metrics slice the
exact same way Define the exact same way
everyone else's metric is defined and
they can see what they look like now it
allows product managers to compare their
metric against other product managers
metric group like I said it's just like
the general group your information your
events falling into and then finally
a combination of all of those things
determines the metric
so
this is a uh just revisiting the table
again
so this is like my first stopping point
for the questions if we have
we don't have any more time I won't go
on but I have a couple slides after if
if we can but basically uh you know we
started at versel there was no data
ownership which we have now because we
can track metrics back to a file on
GitHub that sent the data
uh SQL logic was all over the place not
centralized no documentation that's no
longer the case we have metric
definitions they're in our metadata Tool
uh we have dashboards built specifically
for
these metrics
we know who our audience is that's huge
right if we now know how to build
metrics for
we've aggregated all this into one
source table so every metric can be
traced back through the lineage back to
that metrics enrollment table we're no
longer answering the question of did
something change uh how is this Con how
is this computed where is this computed
when is this computed it's like you it
goes it all just follows one line back
we have standardized time frames you
know daily weekly monthly and we have
definitions of when you actually use
those time frames uh people were had a
you know like I said we're using the six
day weekly metric uh when their product
was like three years old right like and
and so the their product managers were
like you know did this drop because of a
holiday did it shift because no one's
using it anymore it was the time frames
were too small and were too influenced
by time
and you know as if we have time I'll
talk about how we can add segments and
the importance of data ownership
I want to pause here because I'm about a
half an hour and that's what I was told
for more questions
foreign
[Music]